poet and best-selling author rupee core
inspires people around the world with
her powerful words core first rose to
fame on Instagram in 2015 as a young and
controversial voice of feminism now she
uses social media to share her poetry
with millions of followers at just 25
years old core has already topped the
New York Times bestseller list twice her
first book milk and honey sold more than
3 million copies and was translated into
more than 30 languages cores latest book
the Sun and her flowers has already sold
more than 1 million copies we met at the
Whitney Hotel in New York City to
discuss her current world tour and
successful career there are mountains
growing beneath their feet that cannot
be contained rupee core doesn't merely
recite her poetry she performs it bring
your hammers and fists we have a glass
ceiling to shatter let's leave this
place
ruthless which helps explain the rock
star reception she typically receives
sort of a global phenomenon in like two
years with crowds like this one in India
in over 2.3 million more followers on
Instagram Rolling Stone named core the
queen of the insta poets what is an
instant poet I feel like there's a group
of many many many writers and people who
are using Instagram as a platform to
share their poetry and this group of
people has they've been dubbed insta
poets and they've I think brought poetry
into the mainstream
before landing in the mainstream for her
poetry core first gained notoriety after
a controversial post on Instagram this
image of her posing with blood-stained
sheets and pants was initially taken
down by the social media site people
started to get angry and I guess people
were reporting it and what began as a
college art project became a clarion
call for women's equality it just turned
from being like a small project to like
my form of protest if you had to kind of
describe where women are right now in
the midst of this me to movement how
would you describe done I think that
it's so incredible to see I've seen
things that I thought would never change
change and so that's really exciting and
I'm really proud and I want to honor
sort of the women that came before me
now on I'll say things like you are
resilient and you are extraordinary not
because I don't think you're pretty
because I realize that you are so much
more than that writing is very cathartic
and I've used it as a tool to kind of
take myself from a place of victim to
survivor because I don't want to be the
victim I'm not a victim core was just
five years old when her parents moved
her and her three siblings from India to
Canada in your new book yeah the Sun and
her flowers there's a poem called broken
English yeah and you talked about sort
of being ashamed as a child of your
immigrant parents I think about the way
my father pulled the family out of
poverty without knowing what a vowel was
and my mother raised four children
without being able to construct a
perfect sentence in English view that
differently now oh my god so different
growing up it was like mom and dad my
sole purpose in life is to be exactly
like everybody else I don't want to
stand out and so I put myself in their
shoes and I was like wow like I don't
think I could have done it you know my
dad being a refugee my mom and I being
immigrants I couldn't do it let alone
raise four kids and that's when I broken
English because I was like wow your life
is art it's not an embarrassment and you
do belong here
core also honors her native language of
Punjabi by using only lowercase letters
in her poems the sole punctuation is an
occasional period like anybody who does
anything that Garner's a lot of
attention you garner critics yeah some
have have criticized your poetry as
being simple mm-hmm or simplistic yeah
do that you say what is simple and it is
simplistic and that's very purposeful
for my end I want readers to open up
this book and start the poem and from
beginning to end I want the reading
experience to be simple but when they
finish that poem I want
our stomach to turn and then I want them
to sit with that emotion and really work
on that women of color our backs tell
stories that no books have the spine to
carry do you see a lot of women like
yourself and I mean South Asian women
women of Indian descent in art
entertainment on the spines of books I
see it happening more anymore I will say
that when I was growing up they were
very very few and I actually didn't know
any of them because I didn't even have
access to them and they weren't you know
front and center in my face sort of
thing although they were there you know
when I was designing milk and honey it
was so important to see the word core
right on this mind I didn't even want my
first name on it
I just every sick woman has that name
right and so I was like when I want a
seven-year-old to go into a bookstore
and see her name on a buck because I
never got that growing up and it's like
if she sees that she'll be able to see
that she can do it too
so you heard what she said she says
every sick woman has that name core she
means like or seek with the Sikh
religion but suppose it's properly
pronounced Sikh religion has the name
core and so she credits her faith really
with giving her that inspiration she
says it means a great deal that she's
now inspiring a lot of dumb young women
of all different kinds of face to see
their name in print - I love that she's
25 and I love the realization that she
had about her own mother and father it's
interesting as a kid you see them
differently when you grow up and think
you know they're not so bad they're
actually kind of smart I'm very
personable she is finding both her voice
and and that's also a part of culture
too because there are a lot of
gatekeepers in poetry as well who want
to keep out it she went around that yeah
it's really her art I like the message
that it's simple yes it is and
purposeful yeah very important Mike her
a lot she is enormous ly popular